What do imaginary dogs, monsters from another
dimension, and a live decapitation have in
common?
They're all from projects starring these former
Lord of the Rings stars.
Here's what the Lord Of The Rings looks like
now.
"End?
No, the journey doesn't end here."
Since "The Lord of the Rings" days, Elijah
Wood has been an instantly-recognizable star
and has had a delightfully eclectic résumé,
doing everything from high-profile films to
animated voiceover roles to quirky television
series.
Wood provided the voices for Mumble in Dreamworks'
family-friendly "Happy Feet" and Wirt in Cartoon
Network's spooky "Over the Garden Wall."
He starred in the series "Dirk Gently's Holistic
Detective Agency" and "Wilfred," and has appeared
in films such as "Eternal Sunshine of the
Spotless Mind," "Sin City," and "I Don't Feel
at Home in This World Anymore."
“Makes me so furious!
Kevin stop it!”
Most recently, Wood has lent his voice acting
talents to the Disney Channel animated series
"Star Wars Resistance" and Cartoon Network's
"Summer Camp Island," but has also stayed
busy in live action roles, starring in "Come
to Daddy" in 2019 and "No Man of God" in 2021.
Perhaps best known for his role as Frodo’s
right-hand man, Samwise Gamgee, actor Sean
Astin has changed a lot since portraying the
loyal and tender-hearted hobbit.
Prior to "The Lord of the Rings," Astin was
known for playing Mikey Walsh in the classic
children's adventure film "The Goonies," and
as the title character in famous Notre Dame
football walk-on story "Rudy."
Since "The Lord of The Rings," though, Astin
hasn't returned to the film spotlight, appearing
only in smaller supporting roles in movies
like the Adam Sandler comedies "50 First Dates"
and "Click."
Instead, Astin has done a lot of voiceover
work for various animated series, lending
his vocal talents to everything from "Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles" to "Captain Underpants."
Astin has also guest-starred on a wide variety
of television series, including "Law & Order,"
"24," and "Brooklyn Nine-Nine" — and he's
been part of the cast of various live-action
miniseries.
He played Jim Kent on the FX series "The Strain,"
Sunny Gryce on HBO's "Perry Mason," and most
notably Bob Newby in Netflix's mega-hit series
"Stranger Things."
Astin also starred in the Netflix original
sitcom "No Good Nick," which ran for two seasons.
Undoubtedly the most decorated of all the
Lord of the Rings cast members, Sir Ian McKellen
only looks all the more wiser than when he
played legendary wizard Gandalf the White
— and, previously, Gandalf the Grey.
The knighted actor has more awards than you
can shake a wizard's staff at.
McKellen won a Golden Globe Award for his
role in the Made for TV movie Rasputin.
He’s also won two Saturn Awards, an Annie
award, an Honorary Golden Berlin Bear, two
British Independent Film Awards, two Critics
Choice Awards, two Screen Actors Guild Awards…
and the list only goes on from there.
He is an accomplished stage actor, in addition
to one of the big screen's biggest stars — with
The Lord of the Rings merely being another
accomplishment to add to his already extensive
résumé of fine films.
“Here, the hammer stroke will fall hardest.”
McKellen reprised his role as Gandalf in "The
Hobbit" trilogy of films, and has also had
an impressive run as Magneto in Fox's "X-Men"
films.
More recently, he has starred in the National
Theater Live production of King Lear in 2018,
as Gus the Theatre Cat in the movie musical
"Cats," and as a con artist opposite Dame
Helen Mirren in the 2019 film "The Good Liar."
Although Boromir will always be known as the
one member of the Fellowship who tried to
take the ring from Frodo, Sean Bean imbued
the character with warmth and nobility.
“What have I done?
Please, Frodo.”
His loss at the end of "The Fellowship of
the Ring" still feels tragic despite his earlier
actions.
Following "The Lord of the Rings," Bean went
on to appear in numerous films, including
"Troy," "National Treasure," and "Percy Jackson
& the Olympians: The Lightning Thief."
In 2011, the actor took on what would become
his most notable role as leading man Ned Stark
on the first season of "Game of Thrones,"
the hit TV-adaptation of George R.R.
Martin's popular "A Song of Ice and Fire"
book series.
However, spoiler alert, he gets his head lopped
off in the penultimate episode of the debut
season.
Although playing characters who meet tragic
ends is nothing new for Bean, as the actor
is notorious for being killed off in what
seems like every role he's ever played.
Since "Game of Thrones," Bean has continued
to appear in significant roles in films such
as "Jupiter Ascending" and "The Martian,"
although his work has taken a turn toward
television in more recent years.
After starring in the BBC series "Broken"
in 2017, Bean went on to appear in series
such as "The Frankenstein Chronicles," "World
on Fire," and "Snowpiercer."
A household name today, Orlando Bloom is no
longer the immortal, baby-faced elven bowman
we first met in "The Lord of the Rings" trilogy
— despite efforts to make him appear that
way in "The Hobbit" films.
For a while following "The Lord of the Rings,"
Bloom continued to gravitate toward grand
scale, combat-heavy blockbusters.
He starred in the first three films in the
"Pirates of the Caribbean" series, co-starred
alongside Brad Pitt and Eric Bana in "Troy,"
and led the historical epic "Kingdom of Heaven."
In recent years, though, Bloom has drifted
toward more tonally-diverse projects, starring
in the disturbing trauma drama "Retaliation"
in 2017 and the gritty war film "The Outpost"
in 2020.
Bloom has also made the jump to television,
starring in Amazon's Victorian fantasy series
"Carnival Row" and voicing Prince Harry in
HBO's animated series "The Prince."
And he is in the reality-bending 2021 time
travel drama "Needle in a Timestack," in which
he plays a romantic rival to Leslie Odom Jr.'s
temporally-challenged protagonist.
He’s known for playing the more serious
of the two Hobbits who decided to tag along
with the Fellowship — despite not being
invited.
Dominic Monaghan, the actor behind Meriadoc
Brandybuck isn't quite the pipe-weed smoking
halfling we remember from "The Lord of the
Rings" films.
Following "The Lord of the Rings," Monaghan
went on to play Charlie Pace in the first
three seasons of ABC's juggernaut series "Lost,"
a character that possibly rivaled even Merry
in notability.
The English actor also played Chris Bradley
in "X-Men Origins: Wolverine," along with
a number of other film roles that are much
less well known.
After his time on "Lost," Monaghan had regular
roles on numerous television series, including
"Flashforward," "100 Code," and "Quantum Break."
Monaghan also spent several years hosting
"Wild Things with Dominic Monaghan," a wildlife
documentary series nominated for numerous
awards.
In recent years, Monaghan has continued to
act, appearing in a small role in "Star Wars:
Episode IX – The Rise of Skywalker," along
with several smaller projects.
He also has appeared on numerous podcasts,
and still hosts one, along with "The Lord
of the Rings" co-star Billy Boyd called "The
Friendship Onion."
You'd be forgiven for not being able to name
another film featuring Billy Boyd, the actor
behind "The Lord of the Rings'" Peregrin "Pippin"
Took.
No doubt, it would be due to not recognizing
the middle-aged actor because he always manages
to look younger than he really is, much like
a Hobbit.
Boyd's biggest role, by far, was playing the
most confused, pipe-weed toking Hobbit in
the Fellowship.
Although Boyd continued to act following "The
Lord of the Rings," his roles have not been
nearly as memorable.
His most notable part was playing Barrett
Bonden in the Russell Crowe sea epic "Master
and Commander: The Far Side of the World."
But don't be too sad for Boyd, since his true
passion is music.
The famous Hobbit is the front-man for a band
called Beecake, playing guitar and providing
vocals.
Boyd also wrote and performed the end-credits
theme for "The Hobbit: The Battle of the Five
Armies," further lending his influence to
Middle-earth and providing trivia material
for die-hard Hobbit fans.
In recent years, Boyd has guest-starred on
a number of television shows, including "Doom
Patrol," "Grey's Anatomy," and a short arc
on "Outlander."
You'd probably no longer recognize Viggo Mortensen
as the long-haired ranger who launched himself
into a battle with a group of Ringwraiths
on Weathertop, wielding a sword and a flaming
torch.
Now, Mortensen is older and grayer, but still
knows how to command the screen.
Before "The Lord of the Rings," Mortensen
had already come into his own as an actor,
spending the '90s acting in a number of notable
films including "G.I.
Jane," "A Perfect Murder," and "A Walk on
the Moon."
Nevertheless, Peter Jackson's award-winning
trilogy cemented the Danish-American actor's
place in the film industry.
“It’s exhausting being me.”
Mortensen later acted in David Cronenberg
films "A History of Violence" and "Eastern
Promises," the latter earning him an Academy
Award nomination for Best Actor.
Working well together, the director and actor
teamed up again for 2011s "A Dangerous Method,"
which landed Mortensen a Golden Globe nomination
for Best Supporting Actor.
Then in 2018, Mortensen starred alongside
Mahershala Ali in "Green Book," which won
an Academy Award for Best Picture.
Mortensen continues to be a highly in-demand
actor, with numerous major upcoming projects
including Ron Howard's "Thirteen Lives" and
another collaboration with David Cronenberg,
"Crimes of the Future."
Before playing Gimli, the ax-wielding dwarf
who refuses to be tossed — except when there's
no other choice — John Rhys-Davies was probably
best known as Sallah, the affable Arab in
the Indiana Jones films.
Since "The Lord of the Rings," however, Rhys-Davies
has appeared in dozens of films, video games,
and TV series, including both live-action
and voiceover roles.
"Do you know who I am?"
Prior to "The Lord of the Rings," Rhys-Davies
was already a highly accomplished television
actor, with roles in series such as "The Untouchables,"
"Sliders," "Star Trek: Voyager," and "The
Living Daylights."
He continued to pursue all types of acting
after "The Lord of the Rings," making appearances
on dozens of shows, including "Psych," "The
Shannara Chronicles," and "Wizards."
Rhys-Davies has also regularly appeared in
films, although none as big as "The Lord of
the Rings."
Most recently, the definitely-not-dwarfish
actor — standing at a slightly-above-average
6 feet 1 inch — has worked on a number of
smaller films, including "Kingslayer" and
"Bad Cupid."
After getting her start in film starring in
music videos for her father's band Aerosmith,
Liv Tyler made a name for herself in the '90s
in lighthearted films "That Thing You Do!"
and "Empire Records."
She also starred in quieter dramas such as
"Stealing Beauty" and "Inventing the Abbotts,"
before moving on to play Bruce Willis' daughter
in Michael Bay's cataclysmic blockbuster,
"Armageddon".
So it came as a surprise to many when she
was cast as Arwen, the immortal daughter of
the elf lord Elrond and the love interest
of Aragorn in "The Lord of the Rings."
But Tyler seized the role and made it her
own, fitting right in among the rest of the
cast and story, despite Arwen being a much
smaller part of the books.
Following "The Lord of the Rings," Tyler was
one of the first actors to be recruited into
the Marvel Cinematic Universe with her role
as Betty Ross in "The Incredible Hulk."
Although, unfortunately for her, that film
tends to be intentionally omitted from the
MCU canon by most fans, and Tyler hasn't been
seen in the superhero franchise since.
After starring in a few more films, Tyler
pivoted to television, starring as Meg Abbott
in HBO's "The Leftovers" and later as Lady
Isabella Fitzwilliam in the Hulu period drama
"Harlots."
Most recently, Tyler appeared opposite Brad
Pitt in the sci-fi drama "Ad Astra," and in
a 10-episode arc on the firefighting series
"9-1-1: Lone Star."
Hugo Weaving has a knack for playing ageless
characters, starring as the sentient computer
program Agent Smith in "The Matrix" before
taking on the role of Elrond in "The Lord
of the Rings."
However, the two could not have been more
different, with Smith determined to destroy
Neo and his human resistance, while Elrond
worked to save the world of men from Sauron
and the power of the One Ring.
After starring in "The Lord of the Rings,"
Weaving would reprise his role as Smith in
the "Matrix" sequels, and also as Elrond in
"The Hobbit" films, but his iconic roles wouldn't
end there.
He also played V in "V for Vendetta," Red
Skull in "Captain America: The First Avenger,"
and voiced Megatron in the "Transformers"
films.
Weaving's other film roles include "Cloud
Atlas," "Hacksaw Ridge," and the Peter Jackson-helmed
"Mortal Engines."
Most recently, Weaving appeared in the Australian
streaming series "Love Me," and as Dr. Bergman
in the sci-fi thriller "Expired."
For many actors, "The Lord of the Rings" would
be the obvious high point of their career.
However, the role as the elven queen Galadriel
in "The Lord of the Rings" is a mere side
note in Cate Blanchette's impressive career.
The actor owns enough Academy Awards, British
Academy Awards, Golden Globe Awards, and other
awards to fill a house.
She is the first performer to win an Oscar
for portraying another Oscar-winning performer,
thanks to her role as Katharine Hepburn in
"The Aviator."
“There we both are.”
With such accolades, it's clear that Blanchett's
roles on film have been extensive and noteworthy.
Her Oscar-nominated roles also include "Notes
on a Scandal," "I'm Not There," "Elizabeth:
The Golden Age," "Blue Jasmine," and "Carol,"
but her memorable performances go far beyond
that.
In addition to reprising her role as Galadriel
in all three films of "The Hobbit" trilogy,
Blanchett has wowed audiences in "The Curious
Case of Benjamin Button," "Thor: Ragnarok,"
"Ocean's Eight," and "Nightmare Alley."
In 2020, she starred in the FX miniseries
"Mrs. America," and as part of the ensemble
cast of Netflix's miniseries "Stateless."
Blanchett currently has numerous other features
and TV miniseries in the works, and if the
past is any indication, we're sure she has
many more awards in her future as well.
David Wenham, the actor known in The Lord
of the Rings universe as Faramir, has been
busy since his days of fighting for Gondor
and the world of men.
Wenham broke through into the upper-tier of
actors by starring as Diver Dan in ABC's "SeaChange."
It was a highly-successful television series
that helped land the actor an important role
in the second and third installment of The
Lord of the Rings trilogy.
After Middle-earth was saved, Wenham moved
on to a pair of supporting roles alongside
Hugh Jackman and Gerard Butler.
He played Friar Carl in "Van Helsing" and
Dilios, the narrator and warrior in stylistic
Persian-slaying epic "300."
In 2009, Wenham went back to the stage, playing
the title-character in "Jerry Springer: The
Opera," which ran for six sold out days at
the Sydney Opera House.
The following year, he portrayed Melbourne
lawyer Andrew Fraser's long fall from the
top in the Australian television series "Killing
Time."
Most recently, Wenham has had a series of
small-screen roles, including Harold Meachum
in "Iron Fist," Al Parker in "Top of the Lake,"
Jago Zoric in "Romper Stomper," and Price
Galese in "Les Norton."
In between, Wenham has still managed to squeeze
in some film roles, lending his voice to the
"Peter Rabbit" films and appearing in "Pirates
of the Caribbean: Dead Men Tell No Tales."
He can next be spotted as Hank Snow in the
Baz Luhrmann biopic "Elvis."
As Denethor, the merciless Steward of Gondor,
John Noble certainly didn't do much to endear
himself to fans as his character sent his
only living son on a pointless suicide mission.
He then attempted to finish the job by burning
him alive.
Denethor died horribly, first catching fire
on the pyre meant for his son, then throwing
himself from the highest point of Osgiliath
in "The Lord of the Rings: The Return of the
King."
Noble's next major role would prove to be
far more ingratiating, as lovable scientist
Walter Bishop in the hit sci-fi series "Fringe."
Noble starred on the series for 100 episodes
between 2008 and 2013, arguably cementing
that character in pop culture even over Denethor.
Following the end of "Fringe," Noble went
on to appear in a number of television series,
including "Sleepy Hollow," "Elementary," and
"DC's Legends of Tomorrow."
Noble also still occasionally appears in films,
with one of his most recent roles being in
"Silencio."
Currently, Noble voices The Diviner on the
animated Paramount+ series "Star Trek: Prodigy."
After galloping into the "The Lord of the
Rings" films as Eomer [AY-oh-mer], one of
the fearless Riders of Rohan, Karl Urban went
on to have an impressive career following
the conclusion of the trilogy.
He starred in action-packed films such as
"The Bourne Supremacy," "The Chronicles of
Riddick," and "Doom."
Urban's next big break came in 2009 when he
starred alongside Chris Pine and Zachary Quinto
as Leonard "Bones" McCoy in J.J.
Abrams' "Star Trek" reboot.
Urban's impressive DeForest Kelley impersonation
won him the favor of "Star Trek" fans worldwide.
He would go on to reprise the role in two
sequels, with another on the way.
“You’ll love it.”
Urban also entered the Marvel Cinematic Universe
as Skurge in "Thor: Ragnarok," and appeared
in a number of films and television series
in between giant blockbusters, including a
starring role in the short-lived sci-fi series
"Almost Human."
In 2019, he began playing the role of Billy
Butcher on Amazon's popular superhero series
"The Boys."
With multiple major franchises and a super-successful
TV series under his belt, it's safe to say
that Karl Urban has been doing pretty well
for himself post "The Lord of the Rings."
Australian actress Miranda Otto already had
an impressive resume prior to "The Lord of
the Rings," appearing in numerous films and
television series before taking on the role
of the fierce shieldmaiden Eowyn.
First introduced in "The Two Towers," Éowyn
was the sister of Éomer and the niece of
King Theoden of Rohan, who was not content
to hide from battle along with the other women
and children.
She instead disguised herself as a man in
order to fight.
Éowyn was the only character in the films
to successfully take down a Ringwraith, iconically
lopping the head off a fellbeast before killing
the Witch-king of Angmar during the Battle
of Pelennor Fields.
After "The Lord of the Rings," Otto continued
to work regularly in both television and film,
with recurring roles in shows including "Homeland"
and "24: Legacy," and a regular role on Netflix's
"Chilling Adventures of Sabrina."
Next up, Otto can be seen in the upcoming
modern fantasy "The Portable Door."
She will also appear in "All the Colors of
the Dark," a tense immigration drama in which
Otto will star alongside Noah Wyle.
Several years after playing the captain of
the doomed ship in "Titanic," Bernard Hill
would go on to portray a much more heroic
leader as King Théoden of Rohan in "The Lord
of the Rings" films.
Théoden was first introduced as a frail old
man in "The Two Towers," but after breaking
the dark enchantment that had been cast over
him, Gandalf restored Théoden to health and
vitality.
Théoden went on to lead the armies of Rohan
to victory against the Orcs of Isengard despite
overwhelming odds, but ultimately was killed
by the Witch-king of Angmar during the Battle
of Pelennor Fields.
Bernard Hill had a long and impressive acting
career prior to "The Lord of the Rings," and
continued to work regularly afterward.
He appeared in dozens of films and television
shows and earned an Emmy nomination for his
portrayal of David Blunkett in the television
movie "A Very Social Secretary."
However, in recent years, Hill seems to have
taken some time off, with his last significant
role being as the narrator on an episode of
the TV docuseries "Horizon" in 2016.
Still, Hill does appear to have some projects
in the hopper, with several films in various
stages of production.
Buried under piles of greasy black hair and
without eyebrows, you may not have recognized
Brad Dourif from his roles in significant
films such as "One Flew Over the Cuckoo's
Nest" and 1984s "Dune."
He appeared as the sniveling Grima Wormtongue
in "The Lord of the Rings."
A not-so-secret double agent who was loyal
to Saruman while ostensibly serving King Théoden,
Wormtongue manipulated Rohan's king to do
the White Wizard's bidding.
That is, until Saruman's enchantment was broken
by Gandalf and Wormtongue was exiled.
Wormtongue later betrayed Saruman, too, stabbing
him in the back — literally — before being
shot with arrows and killed.
Dourif has provided the voice of Chucky the
killer doll throughout the "Child's Play"
franchise, and continued to do so after "The
Lord of the Rings."
“I don’t believe it.
I just don't believe it.”
He also appeared as Sheriff Lee Brackett in
Rob Zombie's 2007 "Halloween" remake and its
sequel.
Dourif didn't just make horror movies though.
He's appeared in numerous films, as well as
guest-starred on a number of television shows,
including "Once Upon a Time" and "Agents of
S.H.I.E.L.D."
Currently, Dourif is still voicing Chucky
in the Syfy original series "Chucky," and
has roles in several films still in production.
New Zealand actor Craig Parker played Haldir
in the first two "The Lord of the Rings" films,
the Lothlorien elf who first greeted the Fellowship
upon their entry into the mystical woods.
He later showed up to help support the men
of Rohan in their stand against the forces
of Isengard at Helm's Deep.
Tragically, despite the immortality of the
elves, Haldir was slain during the Battle
of Helm's Deep, driving home for both Aragorn
and the audience just how high the cost of
the fighting was.
Prior to "The Lord of the Rings," Parker was
mostly known for playing Guy Warner in the
New Zealand soap opera "Shortland Street.”
The role is one he reprised again in 2007
for the show's 15th anniversary, and continued
to play through 2008.
Parker also appeared in a number of other
television shows in recurring or main roles,
including "Legend of the Seeker," "Spartacus,"
"Reign," and "Charmed."
Most recently, Parker appeared in a recurring
role in the Freeform show "Good Trouble,"
playing pompous artist Yuri Elwin.
In a role that was mostly performed through
motion capture, Andy Serkis didn't have a
lot of screen time in "The Lord of the Rings."
However, he still came out of the experience
as a household name thanks to his brilliant
portrayal of the tragic and singularly focused
Gollum.
Thanks to his nuanced and emotive motion capture
and voice performance, Serkis would go on
to make a name for himself as the go-to motion
capture performer in Hollywood.
He later brought to life characters such as
the titular ape in "King Kong," Supreme Leader
Snoke in "Star Wars," and Caesar in the "Planet
of the Apes" films.
“Ape not kill ape.”
But Serkis also continued to act on screen
as well, appearing in a number of well-received
and highly publicized films such as "13 Going
on 30," "The Prestige," and "Black Panther,"
along with smaller titles that are less well
known.
Serkis also stepped behind the lens to direct
as a second unit director for "The Hobbit"
trilogy, which also saw him reprise his role
as Gollum.
He went on to direct several other feature
films as well, including the recent dark superhero
flick "Venom: Let There Be Carnage."
Recently, Serkis continues to dip his toes
into as many lucrative franchises as possible.
He had his recent role as Alfred in "The Batman,"
and has several projects — including film
sequels, original films, and a video game
voiceover role — currently in the works.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.